yeah yeah in Cape vodka  there is this a brave warrior looks like  got two swords say I've got the stench  of corpses on it you [ __ ] death gonna  say who you are  are you wondering about my swords well  ones for monsters the other for humans  don't touch him  don't even look at him this land never  flowed with milk and honey now it flows  with blood armies have swept through it  several dinars famine grips the bodies  you a Witcher that monster slayer they's  talking about NVIDIA monster trouble  we're not having trouble group [ __ ]  [ __ ] drink  the elder blood can initiate the final  age the time the end  we hacked signed in blogger and a price  to be paid  Sam the land of nerf and wine your grace  vampires